le centre beaubourg se prépare pour une
grande toile est à son ouverture en 1977
l' architecture d'avant-garde avait
soulevé les passions le bâtiment de
verre et de métal que certains
appelaient la raffinerie a pourtant
connu un succès impressionnant c'est
mille personnes étaient attendues chaque
jour elles seront cinq fois plus à le
visiter quotidiennement la rénovation
s'imposait après un succès énorme
plus de 150 millions de visiteurs en 20
ans plus de 25000 visiteurs par jour
il fallait tout simplement rénover le
centre pour des raisons de sécurité même
si l'entretien était bien fait les
travaux imposeront un déménagement de la
bibliothèque et une quasi fermeture de
beaubourg de 5,97 à 20,99 plutôt qu'un
étalement des travaux sans fermeture
le ministère de la culture a préféré que
tout soit prêt à la date symbole de l'an
2000 l'espace sera agrandi pour de
nouvelles ambitions
le bourreau qui réouvrira proposera
montrera expliquera de beaucoup plus la
création du xxème siècle qu'il est
capable de le faire aujourd'hui par
rapport aux espaces qui lui sont
affectés
la rénovation sera surtout un
réaménagement intérieur
la structure du bâtiment n'ait pas
touché et surtout l'état d'esprit
particulier du lieu et préserver ses
premiers ville c'est une petite ville de
la culture dans laquelle on vient pour
une chose pour ça qu'il faut pas mettre
trop d'ordre même le projet qu'on fait
on met bien sûr des lol parce qu'il
remet accompli beaucoup de problèmes
mais pas trop d'hommes
parce que c'est quand même l'inattendu
qui est important dans le sens prôné
loin de faire scandale comme sa création
le centre culturel georges pompidou est
aujourd'hui indispensable au paysage
parisien inévitable sa fermeture
partielle pendant deux ans va frustrer
des centaines de milliers de visiteurs